the fundamental idea behind
psychotherapy
is that we tend to grow mentally unwell
because we haven't been able to think
with sufficient clarity
about the difficulties in our past
typically in our distant childhoods
damaging incidents have been locked away
and continue to have an outsized impact
on us
but we have no way of going back over
them in order to liberate ourselves from
their distorting influences
at the dawn of therapy sigmund freud
noticed that many patients
when asked about their childhoods
provided accounts that were too neat
too intellectual too distanced from the
emotion contained in the events to be of
any use
in order to encourage more real feeling
he made a radical innovation
he asked if his patients might lie on a
couch shut their eyes and enter a dreamy
state that he called
free association he soon found that
these patients recovered far faster
than those who insisted on sitting in
chairs as a result
there are now couches in therapy rooms
around the world
and the past has for many of us been a
lot easier to access
then in the early 1990s an american
psychologist called francine shapiro
became fascinated as freud had been with
the damage done in therapy by our
tendencies to intellectualize the past
rather than relive it not coincidentally
shapiro was at work on a phd in english
literature
which drew her attention to a key
difference between the methods of the
non-fiction essay
and those of the novel in the former an
author provides neat summaries of
positions and emotions
they might tell us that their mother was
often sad and their father frightening
but novelists do something very
different they provide us with scenes
they don't state they show they take us
to a particular moment
and let us experience it vividly through
our senses
with this distinction in mind shapiro
wondered if patients in therapy could
become more like novelists of their
childhoods
rather than just their non-fiction
narrators
and it was here that she stumbled on a
remarkable phenomenon
when we are asked to perform a
repetitive movement like tapping gently
on our knees or our chests from left to
right
or look at a finger moving from side to
side a few inches from our eyes
then our ordinary practical day-to-day
mentality
often seeds to a more trance-like
speculative state of consciousness
something similar can occur when we are
on a long train journey
in a quiet carriage and follow a line of
telephone poles flashing past us
in this state if we are asked to think
back to a scene in our past
we may remember an emotional texture
that would previously have eluded us
we become more like novelists than
essayists
this special state became the bedrock of
what shapiro termed
emdr therapy eye movement
desensitization and reprocessing therapy
the emdr therapist entirely loyal to
freud's basic insight about the need to
bring traumatic scenes back to conscious
awareness
invites patients to return to key scenes
that make them who they now
are often scenes of great difficulty
their first night at boarding school
the day their mother told them about the
divorce the moment they were humiliated
by a stranger
they are helped to linger in the past to
experience it in all its dimensions
the patient might cry in a way they
haven't in years
if ever but the idea is not to abandon a
younger self in one of the most
difficult moments of their lives
it's to help them find a way out of
their pain so an emdr therapist might
after a time back in a foundational
scene ask the patient what they might
want to tell their younger self
they might want to comfort them to
encourage them to be angry
to help them stop taking all the blame
before initiating a session of time
travel
the emdr therapist will also ask a
patient to identify both someone who
gives them support
and someone who is wise these two
characters will then be asked to enter
an early traumatic scene
to give it a new more redemptive ending
a current loving partner might be asked
to comfort a child self
winnicott the buddha or plato might say
a few words to an angry father
or weeping mother in this way
emdr honors the traditional ambitions of
therapy
it renders conscious feelings that have
been shut away and it liberates us from
the influence of the past
through a deeper understanding of its
secrets but it has the added advantage
of allowing us to reconnect with our
histories via sensorily rich scenes
rather than analytical summaries in this
way
the world can become less oppressive and
fear laden
as our formative moments are unearthed
understood
and properly laid to rest
psychotherapy is a set of 20 beautiful
cards each containing a short essay on a
key concept in psychotherapy
creating a pack that offers a perfect
introduction to the subject
you